a lot of expert makeup work goes into
guardians of the galaxy out of all the
characters nobody's look is more
difficult to achieve than that of nebula
daughter of Thanos and villain turned
Avenger
you may recognize actress Karen Gillan
but she definitely looks a little
different in the MCU in order to design
nebulas prosthetics guardians of the
galaxy's makeup team began with a
full-size sculpted bust of Gillan's head
which was used to properly fit the
prosthetics they'd soon be applying to
the actress herself makeup effects
artist David White called the design the
most complex and interesting of any of
the Guardians and likened it to putting
together a 3d puzzle speaking with
business insider white said the five
piece prosthetic was a puzzle of butt
joints and blend offs all on the same
pieces and the density of the prosthetic
changes to accommodate the need to
control the amount of prosthetic
movement from one piece to another in
other words the areas of her face where
Gillan's expressiveness would have to
shine through needed thinner prosthetic
pieces than areas for which this wasn't
a consideration the makeup team applied
the carefully designed prosthetics the
Gillan's head each and every day after
first putting on a latex bald cap which
especially in the case of the first
guardians movie was really kind of a
formality guardians of the galaxy's
version of the nebula makeup required
Gillen to shave her entire head which
she understood would be necessary before
accepting the game speaking with Screen
Rant shortly before the film's release
Gillan said I was told even before I
auditioned that the actors who got this
would have to shave her head and I
didn't think I was going to get it so I
was like absolutely I will shave my head
sure then like three screen tests later
I thought oh god this might actually
happen Gillan famously demonstrated her
dedication at San Diego comic-con in
2013 when the Guardians cast was
introduced she arrived at the event
sporting shoulder-length locks but when
an audience member pointed out that
nebula was supposed to be bald Gillan
removed what turned out to be a wig
revealing her completely smooth dome and
drawing a raucous response from the
crowd at the time she called the look
liberating but admitted later that being
bald it'd take some getting used to I
find the whole thing hilarious at the
time I was like haha bald and then I
woke up in the morning I was like oh God
okay by the time she reprised her role
in guardians of the galaxy vol 2 her
makeups design had undergone a slight
modification speaking to The Wrap before
the flicks release Gillan said I shaved
half of my head
this time but they took away the but
like be underneath half of my hair and
then let the top part that was the best
gift ever for the first Guardians film
Gillan stint in the makeup chair each
morning was nothing short of grueling
being nebulus first appearance in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe the flick was
introduced in a character who had a very
specific look in the comics one which
the makeup team took extra time to
ensure came off looking perfect on
screen it takes about five hours to get
ready in the mornings and it's all just
kind of prosthetic fell over my face and
then an intense amount of pinked the
process involved delicately putting that
five piece puzzle together on Gillan's
face carefully matching the prosthetics
blue shade with makeup wherever her skin
was exposed of course every piece would
have to be a perfect fit including the
cybernetic implants on the left side of
her head once a day's shooting was
complete it was another 30 minutes in
the makeup chair for everything to be
removed during which Gillan would often
serenade her makeup artists and the next
morning she'd have to endure the process
all over again
by the time guardians to was ramping up
production the makeup team had gotten
their process down to the point where
they could essentially cut the amount of
time in half requiring her to sit for
only two and a half hours every morning
once all of the prosthetics are in place
there are several minor touches needed
to finish off the look the parts of her
face not covered in latex need to be
touched up with blue makeup which is
carefully applied with special swabs to
achieve a delicate shading in these
areas more makeup is layered on with an
airbrush finally some fine detail is
provided all around using fine brushes
and stencils which are used to give a
textured look a final once-over with the
airbrush some black shading around the
eyes and a set of false eyelashes
finishes off Gillan's head and neck when
Gillan space and head are being worked
on additional artists tend to her hands
which are also painted completely blue
the same texturing stencil is applied to
the backs of her hands and once this is
complete there's the little matter of
nebulous cybernetic arms to consider as
Gillan is made up and blue all the way
down past her shoulders she's fitted
with a pair of prosthetic sleeves the
right one featuring nebulas lovely blue
skin tone and seams around the shoulder
and the left made to look completely
metallic the right arm also receives the
stencil treatment and fine detailing
Gillan is then given a final once-over
by the team and then there's one last
piece to the puzzle as with the rest of
nebulas looker jet black eyes
also achieved through practical means
according to makeup artist David Weitz
Gillan was fitted with 22 millimeter
black contact lenses which cover her
entire eye to finish off her daily
makeup or deal of course all the makeup
on earth wouldn't make a difference if
Gillan weren't capable of nailing
nebulas physicality and like most Marvel
actors she undergoes a training regimen
which requires an insane amount of
dedication in addition to healthy doses
of cardio exercises like cycling and
running she took part in martial arts
training and lots of it speaking to the
crowd at st. Louis comic-con in 2017
Gillan said I had to do fight training
every day that it wasn't shooting they
told me that you have to do something
six thousand times before it's second
nature I didn't manage to do the routine
six thousand times but we certainly
tried weightlifting is also a critical
part of her routine when preparing to
step into nebulous shoes
the actress told PopSugar I had to
transform myself because prior to
playing the role I didn't do any
strength training her routine before and
during the shoot consists of three days
per week of heavy weight training
interspersed with two days of dedicated
fighting and mixed martial arts it takes
a lot of time an expert makeup work to
transform a pleasant Scottish actress
into a menacing alien warrior but it's
hard to deny that the results are
anything short of astounding Gillan is
nebula is virtually unrecognizable and
according to the actress that's largely
due to the extensive makeup process
without it Gillan says she has a hard
time even reading her lines in one
interview Gillan said essentially I have
the characters skin glued to my face
which is really as close as I could
possibly get to her it's pretty cool and
it's kind of intense and slightly
claustrophobic it's definitely become
like part of my ritual in terms of like
getting into character one time I did a
rehearsal without the makeup and I did
not feel like her at all it's become a
vital part of the process for me check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
you
[Music]